Yeah right that's oh I'm a girl until
someone makes a [ __ ] challenge okay
y'all girls joins a Call of Duty Lobby
say oh girl
hey you guys go for it
you're welcome yeah I'm doing for my
girl my boob this is the one easier to
run through ah jump higher I forget [ __ ]
oh yeah double jump oh I forgot about
that hey jump in the air you may have to
get off of it someone has to stay on the
button to go when the top one goes best
run straight on this thing shut up and
be pretty you like that you like that
Jack oh man
you're king of the hill now you kill
jack there's been worse
[ __ ] sake I'll tell you this and you
don't listen cuz you're out of what
seven [ __ ] dang it game is so laggy no
everybody all watching oh damn it you're
watching killing me alright I got this
sorry this is supposed to be a warm-up
right oh [ __ ] oh no it's just ported me
back to the beginning [ __ ] get away from
me
why are you playing now that even happen
[ __ ] oh okay just a random stained-glass
window in the middle of hips
Brina Church Oh
was gonna make it sorry jack sorry sorry
sorry sorry enemy is really ourself if
you think ya ourself and this bike lock
sorry jack sorry from now on no need to
apologize we're just gonna kill each
other
this is the Canadian version of the game
oh sorry one of us go ahead look at this
look at that no one kill me kill me
please dear God no one kill me
I gotta go get this wait wait I'm gonna
kill you go Jack no yeah the trick is to
skip the first one I think that's how I
did it well just jump straight for the
second whoa okay
no no organize okay I get it folks
except to go make it Ken don't die
Blanka let's copy it did it yeah the
Americans all look at me first right
second I do do it oh you killed me there
Oh
panicked oh yeah hey this thing's like
off st. nails that's hard to get through
it
dancin
okay well him dancing I was not dancing
bounce and then you jump over the spikes
on the Left what oh you are you want me
to show you how it's done
stay down I bounced on you could you
could you scoot to the left a bit if you
dump on me I will [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
happened yeah what happened good point
silver linings from here her harder hard
mateys
I can't make it this can't do it
no like that's the only really hard part
go down just a little too far to the
left oh except to going
[Laughter]
you need to go a little more to the
right you know oh yeah there's frozen
here I can't jump well there you go
you hacks how much she likes who I can't
even get I'm getting worse I'm absorbing
all of your bad skills like geometry
dash is one you just get progressively
worse at the game
oh come on and give me a double G need
to get my Dark Souls mood or my
blood-borne mood because now beat the
cleric beast with my bare hands Jack I
just wasn't recording it so yeah yeah I
did yeah what you can face his head I
know is it like it yeah I know him
personally he does here may have marked
assisted me in the head and I think
maybe yes I was gonna do today but then
this came up so well I'm gonna be I've
been training myself so I'm actually
gonna be good at it like you're good at
this game
shut up hang on oh my god oh [ __ ] oh oh
[ __ ] tell me about you sooner you're
safe if you dodge on that one thing
you're safe all the things Felix does if
you're like oh [ __ ] okay
you could jump jack oh okay now you're
recording I'm playing on 60fps now so oh
oh you need them I need all the frames
god there's so much blood everywhere for
[ __ ] okay reset this map in here's when
I wait it's not red where are we guys I
don't understand it's impossible I got
it hang a bounce
yeah tell me you just bounce on it and
then jump up over the spike there you're
a spy your how would you do that someone
go someone before man I'll take care of
this you guys are making this harder to
get through oh I've got I can go through
this if people would just not kill me
while I'm going through here
magical fook fook unzip decoy
[Laughter]
oh wait no I'm not supposed to go here
[ __ ] [ __ ] noises people make from
this game sorry this is like easier I
know why you guys are dying here like
this parts simple danos that is
magically happen uploaded the other
session made it a proud don't bounce
that whack sorry whatever don't feel
like ok you go first you go through you
but you are the Ferdie woman what how do
you time this you just got a no
appropriate timing is right there where
it's right there pointing can't you see
me pointing over there sorry Ken I can't
okay alright then I can't I have to go I
can't go you guys don't grow the next
part which is really easy really easy to
screw up really I did it on my first try
it's easy okay watch me a fist right oh
[ __ ] sorry
goddamnit yeah
that was like my chance to prove myself
part of the group OOP [ __ ] hey how's it
going how's my ass sounds like a
fanfiction I wrote one time yeah yeah
thought it was my ass okay I was ready
clown fanfiction people didn't like it
all that much I wonder why
hey so sorry he honk-honk was a quite a
good line I try elation on your
curriculum yeah I just want in case
youtube fails I want to know that I have
I have other options yeah I was just
gonna booper dooper my way to victory
booper dooper ooper académica right I
got this everybody watch the second part
is easy 1 you're right I have made
through this part again mainly because
it's my god each other on Oh rectal exam
hey oh ok ah ah ha got him ok
this part again it's easy there's not
much blood over here guys I don't know
where
have you been there yet mouth I've been
down any hole you asked about [ __ ]
everyone's like rushing to get that yeah
I know Wow hey try number two if I could
just get to where Ken is I would be fine
okay Ken this one's complicated you have
to you have this you have to drop down
from that ledge make a turn in there
[ __ ] man second try but everyone always
failing me sure sure
it happened guys don't worry I got this
one looks like the bestest aw you're not
gonna just let me [ __ ] you can jump over
at the Society of Americans so good at
platformers don't ask racism we love
Mario you're the one being racist but
[ __ ] how Davey races against the great
American yeah okay yeah Jack you just
judge us from a different but very Irish
leap very Irish Lee yeah judge us Irish
League goal look at all that we're
sucking days for plenty diesel I feel so
insulted I don't like diesel let me let
me let me do it just go mark I will but
no no no no watch watch
[Music]
we're just gonna watch more it can do it
we did it can you got a fall all the way
down to the bottom left first and then
jump through the gap you see what Amelia
yeah I'm trying I'm sorry to do [ __ ] I
got it the buttons on the right side
though the egg so it doesn't do anything
all right
Harold you get out okay ah it's the
doorway yeah God dang it maybe make it
to the door and push the button yeah you
got an F too right if only you could
drop down like underneath yeah [ __ ] so
much yeah oh yeah oh go oh is that Irish
seducing that's pervert it's just
pervert just general pervert I'm not
nearly drunk enough for seducing
just your are you Brady someone holy
jesus
a bribe raise babies keep hitting that
stupid second when I can't get through
it now yeah I mean either hit earlier
like over here it's actually I I got
there make the very start of the game
and I can't do it I don't know how you
get past that saw sorry sorry cool
thanks oh yeah [ __ ] that
alright I did it [ __ ] yep and I got it
hmm you saw how do you get past that I
don't think you're supposed to that's
what I'm saying guys we go the only ways
I can do it I can do it you guys keep
trying that way I'll keep trying this
way I got this I got this
the way gas Mark's got it I believe in
spikes just gonna stop moving when he
gets back yeah those fireballs yeah
first Felix no no you just did it like a
like a [ __ ] boss not like Jax boss
but like a good boss you know hey what
my no you did this the first time this
is weird
I don't know damn it sorry ladies run at
it
I need some space right maybe you can
like double jump over it [ __ ] Sorry
Sorry Sorry
sliding over hatchet slide on all the
blood if we get enough blood they're
lubricated and then wait there should be
enough meat on here do these not sharp
anymore
stop let's go through let Felix do his
magic I don't know how to do it that you
did it you did it you can do it you can
do okay okay push-ups yeah like that
face oh yeah your national anthem no no
I've never heard it before go what
language is that
Irish I've never heard it before Kona
starship cars you that means why would
my friends wait do you speak fluent
Irish you're British now Swedish
national anthem it was like a Nazi knee
which one is she thinks my tractor's
sexy it really turns your own I did it
no the homeless and not free health care
I got it I figured out the trick never
mind
oh I get it back down and then you it's
like to start and everyone's like nah
that's not how you do it and not
everybody doing it I'm back here I'm
back here and I'm here teleporting ferry
from space to ride me fanfictions right
now okay good
oh I can't do it either are you were
right
I miss George how high I can jump hey
guys watch me I'm a winner I'm a loser
I'm dead this is Joe straighten spikes
where'd you come back okay let's go sit
over here
I'm feeling skills they're elegant it's
bouncing jeez oh this is the first part
out of four by the way I just want to
point that out over here you been in
here yet okay very simple enough time
all day to do it
you just bounce through nope never ever
gonna make that let's try to gauge it
okay things to do okay okay
hit damn it
hey Teddy go under damn it yeah damn it
okay you're welcome
are you [ __ ] okay okay standing doing
nothing why did I die can we
[Laughter]
sorry sorry sorry sorry I should be
protected from all sorry damn it
okay I just want to live alright I got
it wait so this is the game the ruins
friendship oh let me let me fly your
turn
what a gentleman alright now same been
me [ __ ] you and no jack let me okay
there's a roller band or whatever it's
dog [ __ ] sorry ah the order was a
terrible game okay
Judy D I'd be oh are you trying to be a
sneak yeah I almost had it
I'm sorry
I don't chase my tail you just you go to
the corner to jump over the first one
they just run to the second spot by the
Sun the spikes I've even gotten past the
first spikes yet
Oh wrong now yeah two people going
through the second area just messes
everything up
all right yeah do it right that time
no come on the next part of the fire one
is just you can't make oh there's a
platform in the lava all right I can do
this I can do this
you want it I'll be I'll be your
champion I'll be I'll be I'll be the one
[ __ ] I die from Iran possibly okay I
can't believe I can't believe this but
I'm glad it's your me Jack where there
was a second we're not contributing [ __ ]
we might as well be dead look at that
shoot me okay you can sound funny wasn't
Irish like voted the sexiest also go
Jack go go don't [ __ ] up do not [ __ ] up
let's go to make me [ __ ] up though don't
press your jack don't do that don't do
the [ __ ] up thing
why Wentzville watch what do i do you
drop under normally there's a back way
my way do my way [ __ ] they can top damn
it your way didn't work what you're not
me it's the thing that's true let me do
it I can get there yeah
do it some bounces go think I think I
could do it is that thinking go yes I
can confirm no brain
Oh God looking balls get me every time
[ __ ] boys mud [ __ ] balls man I
don't know what to do man it sounds more
South African than Irish I'm so fricking
tomorrow I don't know I don't know I saw
that [ __ ] accent is everyone's
district 9 no yes I did
I completely aligned when I said no I
absolutely know what you're talking
about
hey like stop bouncing gab do just re
the level you just went and made it cuz
you didn't think justice go alright I'm
getting away cuz I want to turn to get
back there cuz if I can get back there I
can win go the option to kick so who's
this grub
who invited him let me think ha
you think away alright can you go can
you go thinking we would have been done
years ago if we'd have been able to go
on at a time you never say god dammit
sorry
oh my god sorry I I vote once we finish
this level of weed suza
teleport in the gun shammy jerks oops
somebody else is already in there
come out of there empty okay go came go
gotta get on this just call mark I got
okay
another thinking around time to get
serious about this no one speedrunning
are you talked I did you talk to me you
know you're not allowed to talk to me I
needed know the timing if you don't have
the time but now Jesus yes still trying
you jump he does first one you wait oh I
think I'm gonna make it up they got all
the way to this level
no no I'm here to stop you from stopping
us now are you gonna let me get my
groove on you don't let you do it
because you did you look up at the other
screen before you go through the yeah
yeah yeah
that's annoying ah I can't get to that
part anymore I can get you go can okay I
don't think we killed each I think we
both just jumped again thank you you're
gonna get me time it no just to stop
mark is teleporting I know I got it max
hang on everybody shut up shut up shut
up shut up
brofist all right whoop okay I see the
end yet but the [ __ ] fire can we a
high note we've asked ready just beat
scared oh god no I mean we only have
like a three minute video so far from
everything at the cut
[Music]
and started